[Music]
come on baby
what up peeps we got more news about the
snyder cut and that is that jared leto's
joker
is making an appearance and this is not
a joke so we're gonna break this all
down for you right now on the ketchup
that's right friends according to the
hollywood reporter jared leto who played
the joker in 2016 suicide squad and
drawing a fair share of criticism is a
part of the additional shooting being
done
for the snyder cut this is all a part of
hbo max's 30 million
investment to turn zack snyder's version
of justice league into a four-part
series coming to the streaming service
in 2021
and that includes a new round of
shooting and completing some unfinished
scenes
of course we got you guys covered for
all things snyder cut so be sure to
check out our past
episodes on those now it's being
reported that shooting is currently
underway with ben affleck amber heard
and ray fisher along with leto but no
word on who else is involved in reshoots
at this point
we're with you till it's done what we do
know is that leto's joker did not
appear in the 2017 version of justice
league that made it to theaters
which zack snyder has said is probably
one-fourth of what he did
in fact the future of leto as the joker
was such a big question mark he could
have changed his name to the riddler
ha ha but with a handful of characters
especially villains
and story lines apparently left on the
cutting room floor it's unclear if
letto's joker was part of snyder's
initial version
or if he's part of completely new
footage being shot for the snyder cut
and if so what else is going to be all
new and will it tie into the rumors
about a possible hbo max series
surrounding ben affleck's batman
who knows not i my turn
either way this now officially ties the
snyder cut to 2016 suicide squad which
was executive produced by zack and his
wife
producing partner deborah snyder back
when they were working on an
overall dc cinematic universe but things
have changed when it comes to dc
universes
now that we know the upcoming matt
reeves directed batman was confirmed to
be in a separate reality from the dc
extended universe
which includes next year's the suicide
squad i know it's
just stay with me here and of course
that leaves joaquin phoenix's joker just
wandering around somewhere in his
own universe as well a universe i only
hope to visit on screen because
man that was a scary movie
alright friends time to kick it over to
you now what are your thoughts on jared
leto coming back as joker i know you
guys have so many feelings on this so
can't wait to read the comments section
and of course if you want more dc news
check out past ketchup episodes and head
to rottentomatoes.com
also if you didn't know we have a
podcast it's called rotten tomatoes is
wrong
and you should check it out because
fresh run is just the beginning of the
conversation and new episodes drop every
thursday
and if you guys don't want to miss out
on any future episodes of this show be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup my name's ask perez and we hope
to see your face in the next video
no joke bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]